欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一个非常重要的板块
就是店铺要选择什么样的赛道才能够获得更多的流量
才能够突破更大的流量天花板
那么为什么我们要确定选什么赛道呢
因为确定赛道相当于确定了我们店铺的总流量的一个天花板
比如说我们选的内幕或者是说我们店铺所定位的一个赛道
都会决定着我们最终能够获得多少流量
或者能够有多少的成交的机会
如果我们没有明确自己店铺的赛道
不知道我们店铺的赛道是什么
那么我们再去选产品
或者是我们在用直动车推广的时候
选的产品就很有可能就是很乱
不知道具体推什么样的产品
具体把时间精力倾斜到哪些产品上面
所以这个赛道对于我们来说
提前明确是非常重要的
另外现在平台是分为四大流量入口
不同的流量入口能够对我们店铺的增长
都是有非常大的影响的
它是决定着我们整个店铺的流量添化板
那么如果我们选对的赛道
流量会更大,商机会更多
所以我们要把我们店铺的赛道明确了
然后去拉升我们整体流量的添化板
这样才能够让我们店铺持续的增长
接下来我们进行详细的学习
比如说你看我的这个框里面
这个框里面代表着整个平台的流量
下面的这个框里面代表着店铺的流量
那现在平台它分为四个流量入口
这流量的入口是比较大的
它是用产品来作为引流的开端
比如说普通寻盲品,寻盲可交易品, 搭贴室产品, 半托管产品
这四大板块在PC和PP端都有流量入口
它们分别是符合这里面的产品
才能够进入各个板块的入口
所以相当于普通巡盘品是一个流量入口
巡盘可交易品也是一个流量入口
RTS产品也是一个流量入口
半托管产品也是一个流量入口
那么它们各个流量入口的
总的流量占比是多少呢?这里的数据是预估的
不代表着绝对的准确
但是通过这些数据的占比
我们知道哪些流量比更多,哪些流量是相对来说比较少的
你看, 这里是10%, 这里是20%, 这里50%, 这里20%
所以我们通过这些流量的占比可以知道
平台更加倾向于RTS产品跟半托管产品, 以及循庞格交易品
因为这些比例它在后期还是会变化的
平台会根据市场发展的趋势和平台的主推方向进行流量倾斜
比如说他最近在推广半托管这个赛道
或者是说这个品类这些产品
那么他就会把流量倒到这边
这边的流量占比就会增加
如果你是做半托管的
那么你的整体的流量可能就会有所增长
但是如果平台在减少这个板块的流量也就是普通寻盘品的流量
那么你整个店铺所有的产品都是普通寻盘品的时候
那么你这里面有可能在下降流量就有可能在下降因为流量都倾斜到了这边
所以我们一定要知道我们店铺的流量是由四大赛道的流量汇集形成的
所以如果你店铺里面只做普通寻盘品的时候你会发现流量的天花板很明显
你无论怎么样去操作好像流量跟寻盘都增长不了
但是如果你增加了一个赛道,比如说你普通寻盘品你再做了, 然后再去发一些可交易寻盘品, 同时把这些产品打造起来
那么你就会发现原来流量的瓶颈在A这个线, 增长到A这个线, 然后你增加了一个寻盘可交易品, 就增加到了B这条, 跳花板这条流量线或寻盘线
所以说他就能够上升一个层级, 如果你在把店铺增加一个RTS产品赛到, 也就是说你店铺里面要发RTS产品, 并且打造这些产品
那么你这个流量层级可能就升到C层级, 也就是说流量, 整个店铺的总流量会更大
如果你再加上这个半托, 那么再增长到C这个流量, 所以说你看4个流量的用口, 能够给你整个店铺
进行一个综合的导流, 如果你仅仅是做定制赛道, 那么你获得的流量可能就是这一点点
如果你再增加许盘可教育品的流量, 那么你再增加一点点
如果你又把RTS做了, 再增加这边, 再把半托做了, 就相当于整个店铺的综合的总流量, 就会大大的提升了
这个是在店铺层级上面去努力
而不是在操作层上面去努力
有些时候你店铺的层已经固定了
你在细节上面无论你怎么操作他的天花板是非常明显的
如果你在这个细节操作上面提升不了店铺的整体的流量层级或寻盘的时候
你一定要往在上一层也就是店铺赛道层级思考
也就是从这四大赛道入口
去进行一个选择过充流量
比如说你原来是做普通群盘品的店铺
那么流量已经达到了一个峰值
你无论怎么操作都无法提升整个店铺的流量的时候
那么你要考虑一下
我是不是可以增加群盘可交易品这些产品
并且去打造一下这些产品
来提升我整个店铺层级的流量
如果你这个也做到了比较好
还缺流量是不是再加一个赛道是不是再加一个赛道
这样的话那么我们整个店铺的总流量就非常大了
按照目前来看
我们平台上面
如果你只做定制赛道比如说就是普通寻盘品和寻盘可交易品
这两种类型的产品那么他的流量占比可能在30%到40%
那么如果你的店铺只做快速交易
搭贴时半拖款你的流量可能占比达到60%到70%
所以你要想一下你的产品
你的公司优势和供应链的优势
适合选择12344个里面的哪几个
来进行展开工作
这是决定让你流量天
店铺流量天花板的一个关键的层级选择
所以这个你要自己去评估
而不仅仅只是在那个细节上去操作
你要从更大的范围去拉升整个店铺的流量和循环
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见